a lot of work went into our April Fool's
video you might have seen it again if
you're watching this stream uh we're
sorry
specifically Rob and our motion graphics
designer Kirk worked pretty tirelessly
on this Rob was up literally all night
Friday to hit the April 1st deadline
yeah here it is uh yeah how do you how
to ride how to control a guardian in
Zelda this is all kind of faked well a
lot of it yeah um it was a pretty fun
thing to do once I completed it uh I
mean it all started in the features
meetings we have every week and Justin
was like we got to think of an April
Fool's thing I think I said ah what if
we like faked link in a tank and Justin
said what about a guardian and then the
room was silent and our eyes all lit up
and next thing I know uh we're trying to
make it happened and so yeah this is all
fake yeah not do any of this by multiple
comments and the comments keep coming I
check it a couple times a day and
there's still people like I mean it says
April Fool's in the title what else you
do with your life you can't read the
whole title I'm sorry
I like well for the Fed to clarify for
the first two days it did not say that
yeah correct
yeah so you wanted to go through or like
we wanted to kind of ask you about the
process of making this because there's a
lot of stuff in that video that is real
but you kind of repurposed it for the
purposes of the visuals and to make it
look like a guardian yeah that's exactly
right
so yeah just you know we have Kirk our
amazing graphics guy who helped me out
you know we kind of it was really fun to
do so we started justin myself and a
couple other people involved we're just
thinking like REO how do we want to go
about making this you know you have to
draw it out right like these are the
steps you need in order to get into a
guardian so we had a lot of things in
the works like we thought about what if
you go to the top of like Satori
mountain at 3 p.m. and whistle and then
wait for a whistle to come back and it
whistle again we were doing all these
steps and then it came down with like
alright it's an item so then we're like
how you do it so I was thinking well
your air items so it's like dragon parts
so I basically made a dragon guide which
people in the comments were like it's
actually pretty good dragon guys
yeah yeah and and then you throw it all
into it you know how else do you make
things will you cook it so you throw it
all into a pot and then we threw in the
giant ancient giant koi or whatever it
is it's a pretty valuable item it is and
I'll bet for everybody who tried it and
wasted a lot of questions got great
auto-saves you can just roll back yeah
it was a lot of people um the comments
were pretty great I mean one guy was
just like god effing damn it yeah my
fake favor excuse me but yeah anyway so
I asked you know we started with Kirk so
here's me I use the early phases I was
like right Kirk can you make me this
prompts we gotta have a prompt right in
order to get into the Guardian and then
I showed him images of Guardian items
and he here he is making the first stage
of the key and there it is final stage
there looks awesome you know like kind
of cel-shaded shadows and stuff and then
I was like all right Kirk this is what
the Guardian looks like I'm he dying to
it so he made a little graphic there
early stages there of the flare and then
that's was a fan of fennec bow the so
that was the other thing is I kind of
know this early on because having if you
know the game there's a phrenic bow
which is like a sharpshooter bow that
essentially lets you aim down sights and
eliminates link entirely from the HUD so
I knew we had to incorporate that so
essentially here's me and then I killed
a guardian which I show going up to so
obviously this is all cut out and so
then here's me basically like right
here's where feasibly I'm cutting this
out and I'm going to start inside the
Guardian so I call the horse bomb arrows
of course and then here's the phrenic so
there you go
and then that's your hide so then us
you're lifted off the ground yeah so you
lift you have that height right which is
pretty key uh so then I'm like yeah just
you know this is this is basically the
footage I gave to Kirk and of course I
had a like hold down aim the whole time
because once you fire it actually goes
back out to a third person so here's me
oh there's another thing too is the bow
Cobbins here you know bomb arrows only
do so much but later in the game you
have silver bow cob ones right those do
not die in one hit so I had to only kill
really low-level
guys which was funny and this is my
favorite right here was I was trying to
get footage for Kirk and I accidentally
made a guardian glitch out so I spun the
camera and put the camera into the
Guardian and got like Generic legit
walking sound effects of the Guardian
just in place moving so that's what I
use for yeah so then here is a the font
we couldn't find the font and I realized
it was all about the a the a I don't
know what type of a you'd call it it's
like um so our stuff on styles go but
anyways I had ended up just getting
screenshots and so I cut out just for
the title and then the rest is a font
that we found but just for the title
ancient Guardian is like actual in-game
font this was this is literally what I
did all night was this type of stuff so
then I added the key and the other thing
that was tricky was if you know in the
pop-up of the menu there's so this is an
upside-down of a skewer I wanted to get
that glow to put behind the key so I had
to like crop out the skewer just enough
to put behind the key I can this is
little like that flare that comes up
behind right like that was pretty
crucial and then here is basically
layered three images so then you have to
concordia tum' link is actually moving
so if you look at it there's actually
bunch of jump cuts but you had to have
link moving behind so I basically have
them stand there and then I cropped out
all the hearts and prompts in order to
you know make it look legit and then
here's the finale
BAM ties the cut did you come up with
that text to you just so girl open sorry
uh Justin is awesome if you read the
text it's really great I forgot what it
says but you just tell the user wisdom
of courage right right
it's it's very much in the same vein of
the style they have for like more
ambiguous mysterious items which is
great and you know here's the final
thing I think maybe you Peter stepped in
and you said I think you'd mentioned the
I so that's kind of like that oh I did
the smallest thing in this hello and I
wanted to show the chat I had with
Kirk fries dough is his late Friday what
I like can you just give me your files
and he's like no dude I won't mess out I
looked over at one point like probably
because I was like semi late for a
Friday I think I was there until 8:00
p.m. that night which is nothing
compared to your 1:00 p.m. the next day
but I've looked over at your Google Doc
that you shared with him for like ideas
and stuff and the title of the Google
Doc was I'm so sorry I'll buy you dinner
at some point an apology for the like in
the title yeah it was good if Kirk is
watching he's I think he's here today
I'll have to go uh buy him some lunch
make good on that promise yeah it was
awesome yes and it was uh you know I was
thinking about it like that morning I
was like pretty delusional thinking like
this is gonna failed no one's gonna
believe this
and I almost wish part of me wish wishes
it was like not apparently so believable
because again some of the comments are
pretty there's still people country like
what though there's so many people who
are like I spent all day trying to do
this I'm like yeah please reload your
save but then on the flip there are some
people who were in on the job just
trolling along with everyone and those
actually gave me the biggest laughs
whereas one guy anyone who was on
defense like I can't tell is this real
or is this fake cuz his April Fool's
some guys like fat better off yeah it's
real and it turns out you can't register
it's tables like when you do like
everyone the town gets scared they kind
of clip through the walls so you want to
like you know expect a patch coming I
don't know people okay cool thanks then
they go try and I guess oh yeah didn't
someone someone start saying like you
need the falling star from like this
area or something I feel like yeah that
was the other one that should've been in
their star fragment star fragment that's
not this again yeah that was awesome
regardless we all had like a work
gathering the next day on a Saturday and
Bob came over and I was like how about
lately really how late were you at the
office last night he's like I just left
the office like an hour ago sick Jesus
but it was awesome is worth it like we
were all kind of joking about the
comments coming and I was like in a car
on the way over laughing it it was at
like 10,000 views before when it said I
like 500k now now it's at I think for
400 420 cosmic 120,000 scuse me yeah but
uh no yeah it's the I think I think
about April April Fool's like you
see these other outlets or even just uh
major companies doing some and it is so
obvious you know and there is a way you
can do it where it's obvious and just
funny but I think this one was fun to
make because it was led legitimate prank
opposed to like a goof and so I think
that was kind of the I do
that's the big difference versus a prank
yeah love it you're usually a goofy guy
so this surprised me oh cool well anyway
you go watch that in its entirety on
gamespot as well as other ones we
mentioned but we like to think that was
the most well done video and whatnot
from April Fool's don't I mean if you
want to try you can still try to do what
the video told you but as we've said
numerous times it's not gonna work I
mean maybe the joke is that it is real
that'd be funny if would Oh what about
zelda dlc what it yeah what if it's part
of the dlc guardian ownership okay
anyway uh yeah Rob would work on that
gurke you're watching same with you
[Music]
you